sans doute plus de 35 minois et quelques
cent mille blessés lors du séisme qui a
ravagé hier le nord de l'iran les
premières équipes de sauveteurs français
sont arrivés sur place
checkpoint charlie a vécu le célèbre
point de passage entre les deux parties
de berlin et s'est démantelée
aujourd'hui la fin d'un symbole au
moment où moscou propose l'évacuation
progressive de toutes les troupes
alliées après l'unification l'allemagne
enfin à san francisco la conférence
internationale contre le sida se
poursuit sur fond de polémique et de
manifestations reportage de notre envoyé
spécial
bonsoir 36000 mans et cent mille blessés
le bilan du tremblement de terre qui a
secoué l'iran n'en finit plus de
s'alourdir il ne s'agit encore que d'un
bilan provisoire
réaction incroyable dans ces
circonstances le croissant-rouge
l'équivalent de la croix rouge sur place
a refusé la présence de médecins de
techniciens de satellites et de chiens
spécialement venus de l'étranger
pourtant toute une région a été rayé de
la carte et les secours s'annoncent très
difficiles christian baisse
un bilan qui galope d'heure en heure un
rythme effrayant au point de dépasser
désormais selon l'onu les trente six
mille morts l'iran est en état de choc
l'iran dans l'histoire est pourtant
jalonné de ces crises sont mortelles
elie de plusieurs sont plus terrible
tremblement de terre et ses parts
villages entiers que les morts
s'ajoutent aux morts car les secours
progressent lentement toutes les voies
de communication sont coupés et c'est un
véritable pont aérien que les autorités
ont dû mettre en place une grande partie
de la zone sinistrée n'a d'ailleurs pas
encore été atteinte par les sauveteurs
le bilan peut donc encore s'alourdir
dans les heures et les jours à venir
face à cette effroyable catastrophe
c'est tout l'iran qui a été mobilisée
que celui d'hier soir
responsables politiques et religieux
appellent la population à donner son
sang au moment de la prière dès
aujourd'hui les iraniens ont répondu
massivement à cet appel donnant sans
argent nourriture et vêtements mais cela
ne suffira pas les besoins sont énormes
pour secourir les dizaines de milliers
de blessés sans abri qui s'entassent peu
à peu dans les hôpitaux de tout le pays
l'iran fait appel dès hier soir à l'aide
internationale de france premier pays à
avoir répondu mais aussi du monde entier
ont commencé aujourd'hui d'arriver
médicaments vivres matériel et
spécialistes pour aider l'iran dans sa
course contre la mort désire vous le
savez des équipes françaises américaines
suisse ou italiennes se sont mobilisés
pour venir en aide aux populations
touchées aux victimes du séisme
les premières équipes françaises sont
arrivés à téhéran en fin d'après midi ce
sont les plus performantes dans ce
domaine gros plan sur ces équipes
d'urgence de la sécurité civile
elle était déjà intervenue à mexico ou
en arménie
laurence vos billets il y a deux heures
ces hommes de la sécurité civile sont
arrivées à téhéran en ce moment ils sont
acheminés vers le nord ouest du pays là
où ils vont intervenir
l'équipe se compose de 205 personnes des
sauveteurs des médecins des maîtres
chiens
un détachement parfaitement en pointe
mais la française est une méthode qui et
je dirai universellement reconnus et
pratiquement utilisé par tous les pays
du monde il faut savoir que la france
est très au point
là est bien souvent forme de nombreuses
équipes des pays étrangers
la technique française a fait ses
preuves en arménie mais aussi à mexico
les maîtres chiens interviennent en
premier sur le terrain les chiens sont
chargés de repérer les victimes coincées
sous les décombres
ensuite à l'aide des coûts très
sophistiqués les sauveteurs ont localisé
très précisément la position des blessés
ces derniers seront alors dégager
rapidement et médicalisée sur place
avant d'être évacuée des opérations qui
freinent du temps il faut environ huit
heures pour sauver des personnes
ensevelies sous des bâtiments écroulés
toutes les troupes alliées évacués du
territoire allemand après la
réunification c'est la proposition faite
par edouard chevardnadzé ce matin à
berlin proposition pas tout à fait
innocente elle engage au moins autant
les pays occidentaux le ministre
soviétique des affaires étrangères avait
aussi soigneusement choisi le lieu sa
déclaration berlin berlin ou plutôt
checkpoint charlie le plus célèbre point
de passage entre l'est et l'ouest
checkpoint charlie supprimer ce matin le
symbole de 30 ans de guerre froide a
disparu
enlevez tout simplement par une grue
philippe pisteurs
une simple guérite qui s'élèvent aux
accents d'une fanfare militaire
checkpoint charlie a vécu presque trente
ans de bons et loyaux services une
cérémonie d'adieu en la présence des
ministres des affaires étrangères des
alliés de la deuxième guerre mondiale et
le ce des deux allemagnes check point
charlie
le plus célèbre poste de garde
interallié entre les deux parties de
berlin situé en secteur américain
checkpoint en bon français points de
contrôle
pourquoi charli tout simplement parce
que c'est le troisième point de passage
côté occidental
charlie et en l'identification
internationale dans le jargon radio de
la lettre ses 22 septembre 61 5 semaines
après la construction du mur
checkpoint charlie est installé histoire
d'affirmer le droit des trois alliés
occidentaux à circuler dans tout berlin
octobre 61 la guerre froide a failli
devenir chaude pendant deux jours chars
soviétiques et américains
on se perd face de part et d'autre avant
que moscou ne sonne le repli depuis le
mur a pris la r1 des derniers symboles
de la guerre froide aujourd'hui
disparaît direction le musée
l'europe 7 fois au centre des
discussions entre françois mitterrand et
helmut kohl aujourd'hui en rfa après une
mini croisière sur le rhin les deux
chefs d'état se sont entretenus en
préparation du prochain conseil européen
de dublin pour les deux hommes il est
urgent d'accorder une aide économique et
technique à l'urss il y a urgence a
déclaré françois mitterrand lors de sa
conférence de presse commune avec helmut
kohl elena bonner a paris si la veuve du
prix nobel de la paix andrei sakharov
présenté ce matin une exposition de
peinture au service de la liberté le
symbole du combat d'une femme qui se bat
toujours pour les droits de l'homme
nathalie et de perles a rencontré la
force de l'âge et la volonté de vaincre
la solitude à 67 ans elena bonner
parcourt l'europe à la recherche d'un
idéal qu'elle voudrait faire partager à
toute l'humanité
elle a connu l'exil la guerre la maladie
aujourd'hui le prix nobel d'andrei
sakharov revêt toute sa signification
dans la bouche d'elena bonner un seul
mot la paix je ne m'inquiète c'est pas
trop du sort de l'urss
ce qui m'intéresse c'est que les enfants
du tadjikistan ne meurent pas de faim
que ceux d'arménie ne soit pas dépenser
pour elena bonner la machine soviétique
n'a pas changé le couple sakharov en a
fait la triste expérience
aujourd'hui elena ferme les yeux sur le
passé mais aussi sur le présent je pense
que le gouvernement soviétique et
monsieur gorbatchev n'ont pas de
politique à part une lutte féroce pour
le pouvoir entre kiki je ne sais pas je
ne tiens d'ailleurs pas à le savoir est
né le rouleau après paris peut-être
londres ou rome
ambassadrice des droits de l'homme elena
bonner a bien l'intention de poursuivre
sa lutte jusqu'au bout
en france fin du comité central du parti
communiste ce soir place du colonel
fabien après trois jours de discussions
georges marchais une nouvelle fois
contesté par de nos femmes pourtant bien
éloignée
charles fiterman et philippe herzog en
portage
elle varie pas menti 1 georges marchais
serein c'était il ya deux jours à
l'ouverture du comité central du
ici comme il fallait s'y attendre les
reconstructeurs groupés autour de
charles fiterman ont renouvelé leurs
critiques mettant en cause une fois de
plus les statuts mêmes parties
inattendue en revanche la montée au
créneau de philippe herzog l'économiste
du pc lui stigmatise la
social-démocratie et l'attrait qu'elle
exerce sur certains camarades dans le
collimateur bien sûr charles fiterman et
les droitiers au centre le rassembleur
georges marchais qui lance cet appel
cet appel j'en ai la conviction répond à
ce que pense à ce que veulent les
communistes
naturellement cela ne veut pas dire
unanimis jamais n'en poser des questions
comme cela n'est pas mais ils y ont peut
et on doit travailler avec ce souci de
l'unité du parti sur la base nature
helmand d'une bonne politique
1 georges marchais plus combatif que
jamais il y a tout à parier qu'au soir
du 22 décembre à l'issue du 27e congrès
il soit reconduit dans ses fonctions de
secrétaire général à autre chose
évidemment c'est à la fois une mauvaise
nouvelle et un chiffre inquiétant la
criminalité a sérieusement augmenté
cette année en france cela n'était pas
arrivé depuis cinq ans palme d'or
étonnante de la progression la
délinquance
la paisible ville de laon dans le nord
de la france avec 1137 crimes et délits
recensés en 89
la criminalité a augmenté de 36 % en un
an la population reste incrédule
reportage nathalie burrus fr3 lille une
augmentation de 36% des actes de
délinquance dans une petite ville de
province paraît à première vue alarmant
il s'agit cependant de relativiser cette
affaire même si les dégradations de
véhicules et les chèques sans provisions
sont en progression
les atteintes aux personnes restent
rares un fait rassurant pour une
population qui garde la tête froide sur
kazan je suis installé j'ai eu
un chèque sans provision et à chaque
volet c'est tout j'avais pas vraiment
pas cru qu'il y avait tant de
délinquance a lancé calme jusqu'à moi
j'avais parlé d'une agression à l'eau
c'est bizarre alors si on recherche la
cause du mal on s'aperçoit que la
jeunesse de l'ensemble cruellement pas
de bowling pas de boîte de nuit en ville
la séparation entre la ville basse et la
haute n'arrange pas les sang mais un peu
quand même
alors en attendant qu'on leur trouve des
activités plus saine que le casse de
voitures mairie et préfecture tente de
faire face à cette recrudescence de
délits en se partageant tant bien que
mal prévention et répression
deuxième journée du congrès mondial sur
le sida à san francisco au centre des
discussions la z tu es le seul
médicament connu pour faire reculer la
progression de la maladie
san francisco capitale du sida pour ce
congrès est dans les faits la ville
compte à elle seule 8700 mah là d'autant
que dans toute la france conséquence des
infrastructures et un réseau d'aidé
d'accompagnement aux malades ont été
mises en place une organisation très
efficace reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux
jean-pierre quinson et philippe basque à
san francisco l'homosexualité à droite
cité dans certains quartiers comme ici à
castro street les gains sont en majorité
depuis dix ans cette communauté de 70000
personnes a été frappé de plein fouet
par le sida on estime qu'aujourd'hui
plus de la moitié d'entre eux sont
séropositifs des chiffres qui ont
contribué à modifier un peu les
comportements en saura un peu moins
c'est à dire cette vie
y'a secondaire mais caso et terre pour
trouver des partenaires pour la nuit à 7
lifestyle
cette manière de vivre a complètement
changé
l'utilisation des préservatifs a
également contribué à enrayer un peu
l'épidémie mais il faut s'occuper de
ceux qui régulièrement entre dans la
maladie nisha et psychologue de
formation elle appartient à la
communauté gay depuis trois ans comme
700 autres volontaires
elle travaille pour le chant ty project
la principale association dead aux
malades de san francisco son rôle en
prendre en charge quelques uns et les
entourer tout au long de leur maladie
elle lui coûte 1
on dîne ensemble on va au cinéma on
s'assoit on discute pfff exactement
comme je pourrais le faire avec
quelqu'un de ma famille ou avec un autre
ami ultime aspects du sida à san
francisco cette maison qui est derrière
moi elle s'appelle coming home auspices
et s'adresse aux malades du sida qui ne
veulent pas mourir à l'hôpital
ici les soins ne sont que palliatifs les
patients séjournent en moyenne une
cinquantaine de jours
il y a presque toujours quatre ou cinq
personnes en attente 9e jour de grève à
la sfp et le mouvement était reconduit
ce matin par le personnel quelques
heures avant le début du comité
d'entreprise c'est eux qui se tient
depuis le début de l'après midi au sujet
bien sûr du plan de restructuration qui
prévoit 500 suppressions d'emplois
pourquoi la société française de
production est elle arrivée là
réponse avec bernard ségara et philippe
guinet ce plateau déserté aujourd'hui le
plateau 14 et le dernier né des buttes
chaumont
ils possèdent tous les raffinements de
la technique preuve que la sfp est resté
le fer de lance de la production d'image
ce qui la mine depuis sa création tient
tout à la fois de l'absence de fonds
propres elle est obligée sans cesse
d'emprunter et de payer des frais
financiers considérables tient aussi de
l'obligation impérative d'être rentable
dans un marché devenu totalement
concurrentiel enfin on personnel
permanent qualifier mais trop nombreux
selon la direction pour une production
qui n'est pas constante pas d'accord
répondent les syndicats séparer deux
fois être nombreux par rapport à quoi
ça veut dire quoi s'il était de frais
trop nombreux n'aurions pas tant des
intermittents et l'occasionnel il
n'empêche 383 millions de pertes l'an
passé pour un chiffre d'affaires d'un
milliard de francs avec des masses
salariales qui représentent 60% de
l'ensemble des charges il devenait
urgent de prendre des mesures pour la
survie de l'entreprise mesures
approuvées cette fois par le
gouvernement lorsque nous mettons nos
tarifs à égalité avec ceux du privé ce
que nous sommes obligés de faire pour
conserver nos marchés eh bien nous
perdons de l'argent parce que nos coûts
de revient sont supérieurs aux prix du
marché les producteurs privés longtemps
pénalisées par l'obligation qu'avait les
chaînes de faire travailler la sfp se
réjouissent ouvertement de la fin de la
chasse gardée des cpu n'est ni trop
grosse ni trop petit il faut qu'elle
soit sur le marché comme les autres tout
ce que nous disons il ya la place pour
des entreprises de plusieurs tailles et
aliette aujourd'hui dans l'activité de
production des producteurs indépendants
qui ne sont pas tellement loin d'être
aussi groupe fft en volume en budget de
production si vous voulez de fiction une
fois vendu une partie des immeubles des
buttes chaumont pour investir notamment
à bry-sur-marne la sfp en temps nous et
ensuite des alliances avec d'autres
partenaires financiers pour devenir un
groupe de dimension européenne
l'europe a besoin en effet de 120 mille
heures de programmes et elle ne peut en
créer que 20000 sera telle contrainte de
sacrifier sa culture et son savoir-faire
pour s'aligner sur la concurrence
américaines ou japonaises
tout de suite les autres faits marquants
de l'actualité en france grâce aux
images de nos stations régionales
commentaires laurence piquet le jeune
autiste de 70 milles qui avait disparu
mardi dans les cévennes a été retrouvé
cet après-midi sains et saufs
c'est un habitant de la lozère qui l'a
découvert à 15h assoupi dans un buisson
aaron sabah a semble-t-il parcouru 5 km
dans la garrigue
ils s'étaient égarés dans le gîte rural
du parc naturel des cévennes 200
pompiers et gendarmes avaient ratissé le
secteur
pronostic des médecins est réservé
aujourd'hui sur l'état de santé d'un des
cinq pompiers roulé hier après-midi dans
l'incendié du site de brégançon dans le
var ce premier ministre de l'été a fait
deux morts et a détruit 100 hectares de
végétation
il serait d'origine criminelle ce
château ariégeois deviendra t'il une
base pour les militants d'extrême droite
le propriétaire de la demeure située à
la sortie du village de saint paul de
jarrat près de foix a signé une promesse
de vente à des clients proches du pn et
feu parti nationaliste français et
européens l'acte définitif de vente
devrait être signé à la fin du mois
le maire du village s'insurgent les
habitants se mobilisent ils vont créer
un comité
enfin un nouveau paradis à brest pour
les amoureux de la mer il s'appelle
océanopolis tu son but présenter toutes
les technologies liées à la mer toutes
les espèces trouvées au large de la
péninsule bretonne
les visiteurs peuvent même dialoguer
avec les plongeurs dans les aquariums
quatre cent mille personnes sont
attendues dès cette année les épreuves
du bac continue principal terreur des
candidats les épreuves bien sûr mais
aussi les correcteurs pendant le bac les
enseignants souffrent eux aussi s'ils
tentent d'échapper à cette tâche
harassante et sous payés portrait d'un
des six mille cinq cents professeurs
correcteurs de la région ile de france
anne moreau et pierre michel pour la
quatorzième année consécutive
françoise terreur se rend au lycée ou et
les correctrices pour prendre possession
de ces copies de français 77 copies
anonymes à corriger en 15 jours et payer
3 francs pièce salaires de misère pour
un travail souvent mal aimés les
candidats ne sont pas les seuls à
angoisser devant leurs feuilles d'examen
cette année à première vue les choses
s'annoncent bien je crois que ce sera un
bon paquet de copies
ça a l'air assez dans ce cas peu de
copies qui font une page où une page et
demie
et puis dans leurs présentations sont de
bon augure
les parties sont bien bien nettement
séparés l'introduction le développement
la thèse et ont pas l il en arrive à
l'antithèse voilà quelqu'un qui a eu un
bon professeur là toute la vie tous les
matins chez elle françoise terreur
s'installe devant 10 copies maximum
discipline sans corriger idéal le
français exige une attention soutenue
quatre critères à prendre en compte pour
attribuer une note la compréhension du
sujet la logique l'utilisation des
exemples et l'expression les fautes
d'orthographe
elles peuvent coûté deux points aux
candidats et l'impression d'être
impartial c'est cet amant kiné afin
c'est un mot que je comprends bien c'est
un mot que les élèves utilisent souvent
maintenant face à une copie on a
certainement des consignes qui nous aide
dans cette impartialité mai
ce sont des messages malgré tout
personnel que livrent les élèves et nous
ne sommes pas des robots en juillet à la
remise des copies
françoise terseur participera à la
commission d'harmonisation son rôle
veiller à ce que les notes soient
homogènes
à défaut d'être bonne l'an dernier
encore la moyenne nationale en français
était de 8 sur 20 seulement football
mondial et journée de repos aujourd'hui
pour toutes les équipes avant les
demi-finales qui se joueront à partir de
demain après midi et jusqu'à mardi soir
alors émis gullit cialis et la coupe du
monde a jusqu'ici parfois de belles sur
les matches à venir vont-ils tenir enfin
leurs promesses
et bien tout le monde l'espère pour la
première raison qui est que tous les
matchs maintenant se déroule avec
élimination directe c'est à dire ça
passe ou ça casse si on est un score de
parité à la fin du temps réglementaire
prolongation et si ça se poursuit
tirs au but et la deuxième explication
elle est flagrante regarder le premier
panneau je vous ai proposé
il suffit de voir rfa pays bas qui sera
en direct dimanche à 21h sur fr3 en
direct depuis mille ans rf-a pays bas
c'est pratiquement une finale il y aura
aussi brésil argentine dimanche 17h à
turin angleterre belgique mardi à
bologne italie uruguay lundi à rome
alors une fois qu'on a vu ce tableau on
peut déduire très facilement que
l'italie devrait se qualifier pour les
quarts de finale l'uruguay n'a pas
étonné grand monde au cours de la
première partie de ce mondial
brésil argentine au cours des neuf
dernières années le brésil a
pratiquement gagné tous ses matches
l'argentine n'a gagné qu'une seule fois
donc le brésil pourrait l'emporter
le grand choc c'est rfa pays bas il
faudra aussi surveiller les tribunes ce
qui se passe autour du terrain car à
milan la semaine dernière les hooligans
ouest allemand avait fait très fort
malheureusement et les hooligans
hollandais ne sont pas des tendres non
plus à part le football c'est beaucoup
plus intéressant les petites équipes
nous ont beaucoup surpris pendant la
première partie du mondial est ce
qu'elles vont tenir pendant les
huitièmes de finale je pense notamment
une équipe comme le costa rica
ben je vous dire que tout le monde
l'espère en tous les cas tous ceux qui
aiment le football l'espérance où les
surprises c'est sale et surprise c'est
par exemple regarder le second tableau
le costa rica qui va être affrontée à la
tchécoslovaquie malheureusement pour
wang kai a sauvé les siens samedi à 21h
à baril ça sera presque mission
impossible
cameroun colombie ça c'est un match qui
sent bon le soleil samedi à 17h à naples
est roumanie et puis espagne yougoslavie
donc les petits ont peut-être encore une
chance de s'en sortir tout ce qu'on peut
dire c'est que c'est très difficile de
faire un pronostic pour ces trois ans
peut-être simplement cameroun colombie
c'est un parfum du meilleur café du
monde
et puis c'est le coup de soleil ce
mondial question habituelle est ce que
vous avez un diagnostic pour la finale
alors les diagnostics alice je n'en fais
jamais parce que je me trompe toujours
en revanche ont pu avoir brésil italie
ou belgique ou angleterre rfa en demi
finale ce qui pourrait dire une finale
italie rsa meilleure défense contre
meilleure attaque mais je ne suis pas
madame soleil
merci si la vague déferlante des rolling
stones arrive sur paris avec un premier
concert ce soir à cette occasion une
radio privée canal 9 a décidé de
consacrer 24 heures de son antenne aux
mauvais garçon du rock'n'roll 24 heures
d'antenne et 25 ans de carrière
flash back michel vial karim au cou lui
27 ans de chansons revisitées en 24
heures c'est le pari un peu fou engagé
depuis ce matin 7 heures par canal 9
nous chanterons des chansons de chaque
époque de nos débuts jusqu'à aujourd'hui
précise et mick jagger en mars dernier
en lançant sa tournée européenne de 1963
à 1990 entre les rebelles désinvolte des
années 60 et le groupe devenu mythique
et presque conforme le quart de siècle
d'un parcours chaotique voire hors la
loi et une exceptionnelle perception du
rythm'n blues avec son odeur de misère
et d'oppression que l'europe a intégré
et banalisé
le rock / et tout le monde est partie
prenante de cette future donc les stones
se font partie de cet héritage de cette
culture
ils ont participé à la construction de
ce mythe et maintenant ils sont toujours
là donc c'est vrai qu'il prouve à la
fois qu'on peut être musicien de rock
encore à 50 ans mais bon si ça moi paris
des femmes à sec
matolcsy
m
la célébrité démesurée et les années de
débauche n'ont pas gâché la silhouette
androgyne de mick jagger l'ancien dans
dc vol est révolté est devenu à 46 ans
un professionnel placide et mondain et
son narcissisme impénitent le protégera
sans doute longtemps encore de la
vieillesse
regardez
les
les jeunes
viens
m
voilà fin de cette émission si vous
n'allez pas voir les rolling stones ce
soir les programmes sur la 3 à 20h35
thalassa avec un superbe reportage sur
les baleines à 21h35 un téléfilm de john
schlesinger chez schlesinger j'y arrive
en anglais à l'étranger à 23h05 faut pas
rêver de présenté par sylvain augier le
prochain rendez vous avec l'information
c'est à 22h40 soir 3 présenté par marc
hautement à lundi bonsoir
à